[Music]
and historic moon mission is setting the
stage for a new space race this time
between the US and China the Chinese
Chung efore Lander took this photo of an
orange tinted landscape on the far side
of the moon on Wednesday it became the
first space probe ever to land there
mark strassman shows us how this
breakthrough may intensify u.s. chinese
rivalry the Chinese have landed their
Rovers high-definition images show the
moon's far side the one that never faces
earth China intends to be a space power
to walk on the moon and eventually
establish a lunar base
the Asia society's Isaac stonefish is an
expert on us-china relations and what a
change it's been from a year ago several
years ago when the question was can
China innovate 10 China keep up and now
it's more of a question of are they
reaching parity and what happens next
all six crude Apollo flights beginning
in 1969 landed on the moon's near side
12 men all Americans left flags and
footprints the last time in 1972 NASA's
focus then shifted to low Earth orbit in
2017 President Trump
signed space policy directive number one
the moon is again America's top
spaceflight priority it's time to take
all of what we've learned on the
International Space Station and go to
the next step for a permanent presence
on and at the moon gym bridenstine
NASA's administrator talked to us about
the symbolic and scientific value of
landing again on the moon we're the only
nation on the earth that's done it all
these other nations want to do it how
important to deeper space exploration
Mars wherever is a lunar presence it's
critical so this gives us an opportunity
to prove how are we going to live and
work for a lengthened period of time
I'm on a world that's not our own NASA
is planning for a solar-powered mini
Space Station to orbit the moon called
the lunar gateway the next step to a
Mars mission partners will include other
countries and other companies their
competition China we are reaching a new
era of us-china relations that seems to
find more by competition and
collaboration and a space race could
certainly be a part of this future a
glimpse into that future just landed on
the far side of the Moon for CBS this
morning
I'm mark Strassmann it is the next
frontier in terms of a defense space
race in answer is China's our number one
competitor up there right now